welcome to film courage episode number
141 my name is Karen warden you know I'm
thinking care no I'm wondering if we
should change the music in the beginning
of our intro maybe some Gregorian chants
or something like that that's good
trance music I like it you know we need
some music submissions and try to figure
out who I know you've been talking about
that for a while yeah you know I'd like
to just kind of keep it fresh I mean I
like the music but we've had it for a
while and it's kind of reminiscent even
you know maybe an 80s metal band and
that's cool i like i like that music but
yeah I'm ready to kind of change things
the Feng Shui show a little we have any
musicians out there they're listening ok
cool you know we're actively taking
submissions my name is David Brandon you
can connect with us on YouTube Twitter
Facebook and at film curse calm we have
a special you know I argue no surprise
sort of co-hosts here in studio that the
lovely Elizabeth car is joining us here
in studio today Thank You delighted to
be here yeah I'm glad to have you
Elizabeth car co-produces and acts in
radio free album of radio free album
with is a film based on the novel from
the brilliant and often misunderstood
philip k dick radio free album muth is
currently playing film festivals all
over the US and abroad at stars shea
whigham Katheryn Winnick Alanis
Morissette and Scott Wilson yeah
elizabeth is a very busy lady her acting
roles include house ER Women's Murder
Club Veronica Mars sleeper cell the west
wing as well as many others beyond all
that we just enjoy having Lizbeth show
so so thank you for joining the studio
let's welcome Elizabeth cars yay thank
you and I'm thrilled to be here with
Elena so what an exciting guest yes it
really is and I've been waiting for the
show for a long time and that being said
our guest today is filmmaker lynus
Phillips lynus is a graduate of New York
University's experimental Theatre Wing
he started out as a live performer of
experimental theatre and alternative
comedy while living in New York City his
credits include walking to runner which
is Lynn as's first feature film about a
trek from Washington State to LA to meet
Furner Herzog great speeches from a
dying world about several homeless
individuals for
Seattle the the film uncover
circumstances that have landed in kept
those people lost and painless most
involving abuse addiction and mental
illness than that that's his second film
which linis wrote directed and starred
in also by the name of linis Phillips
about a man coming off of a disastrous
affair with a married woman and has a
sort of lyrical strange and comedic
cross-country journey in a modified VW
bus please welcome to film courage via
telephone mr. linis Phillips welcome
with us hey hey nice to hear my dad's
voice that is that was that your real
dad yeah yeah is he really an
electrician wow I love that scene where
you call it telling them that you needed
your TV fixed that's great oh right
right right that's a real story story he
used to have you know people call him up
all time because there was a he's like a
like a contractor more like construction
jobs stuff but he would have people
calling up because there's a place down
the street from us called philips TV
repair so they would you know they
thought was the TV repair anyway well
let's find out more about where you grew
up and your life as a kid linis was this
in Massachusetts sure is it okay if I
just do some dishes here yeah that
sounds good yeah why don't you ring yeah
Rangel any on barking dogs tonight yeah
we can hear that yeah and can you call
your dad because I'm having trouble with
my reception there you go yeah dizzy fix
rabbit ears you know it makes me wonder
how many people listening live or are
doing their dishes right now you never
know so maybe he's channeling he's
picking up from the ether you know
things that other people are doing but
uh oh yeah going by child childhood like
I grew up in you know outside of Boston
and
then went to NYU and lived in New York a
good chunk of my adult life yeah um I
don't know I was a quiet kid what do you
want to know what I wondering what did
you like to spend time doing as a kid
did you make up stories did you actually
yeah I would play with um like action
figures toys like GI Joes Siskin often
with friend I guess I didn't have a lot
of friends but you know I would have a
couple and that we would just play these
big dramas and stories you know with all
these characters and stuff I die like
that I used to make my own dolls by a
cutting out like out of jcpenney
catalogs and things I'd make my own
paper doll so maybe I was kind of a long
like you too oh okay yeah and I used to
play with Barbies too i think that's
something that you know we just have
active imaginations were you an only
child lineThe no I have an older sister
and older brother and a younger brother
oh wow and I think from my younger
brother was born when I was seven and so
I think that's partly why I got into
working with kids because I took care of
him so much so anyway I worked as a like
a nanny a lot while I was in college I
just kind of kept doing it I don't know
so um it wasn't it wasn't too much of a
strange transition kind of just start up
up and making films because like I guess
I kind of never really had like a job
video too much of a straight job
basically um you know it was just like
okay I'm gonna stop working with this
kid he's getting older now and then I
focused more on creative stuff anyway
but in a way wasn't working with kids
what was your initial foray into making
films Edgar uh true yeah a couple oh
yeah I actually maybe it was because I
thought it would be a fun project to do
with this boy because he had dreams and
like fantasies you know he want to
uh he loves to pretend to be the
babysitter the one in charge you know
and it's I think really therapeutic for
the kid to just be like you know and I
played the kid in this one video we did
call the bad babysitter and he have to
just yell at me q go with the lights at
this boy Oh Victor had it just saying
you know I think a swear or something
and he knew he could kind of get away
with it but it was also not too good for
him to do it was just that edge of
pushing in the very healthy way what he
could get away with right every kid's
fantasy right to yell at the babysitter
Linda did you move around a lot as a kid
because I noticed that some of the
themes in your film involved traveling
you know with walking to Verner you take
the trip from Seattle via foot to LA and
then with bass ackwards you're taking
this trek across country so it seems
like you're drawn to that that theme no
I never did um really travel until I
went to school I mean I I was for a
semester in Germany in high school but I
don't know my mom I mean I guess I don't
know if this they came from here but my
mom kind of traveled from what she was
born in Lithuania and they actually she
and her parents and her sister walked I
guess from Lithuania to Germany I'm not
even sure how long that is but they have
no other way to kind of you know leave
their their life there so it was kind of
funny wind up my walking thing came up
and my mom was saying oh you know that's
kind of what there's a connection there
oh just uh that's nice yep but I think
those the films i've made about
traveling the films i've made up until
now you know are the kind of film where
you're discovering it as you're making
it and it's kind of very much about
the themes going on in your life right
then so you know it was kind of
happening during that time not not from
the past or whatever so from your time
working with special needs kids what did
you take away from that what did that
teach you you said you never been drawn
to sort of the quote-unquote real job
which is definitely taking care of kids
is a real job but what did you take what
did you take away from all that oh good
lord um just eat connection with
children I mean hopefully I won't sound
like a perfect no I bring I really no I
generally love kids and I think I have
something very a non-judgmental way of
being with them which i think is really
important um reading a book now about
Manson and someone who started to write
about him who's a psychiatrist and he
was talking about the power of he works
with mentally ill people and just just
the power of listening to someone
without judgment it's just such a simple
and yet you know something so necessary
for people's existence you know and I
think I've been able to do that with a
few kids and you know it's something I I
hold dear yeah and I think too I would
knowing knowing your pension for artists
and and and and for artistry is that
there's such a lack of arts education
right now in the in the schools and in
general so to give that to kids to let
them use their imagination and pretend
to be someone else or see what the
possibilities are I I think that is so
huge and wonderful and something I do
too so I can
I I really think that's an important
thing you're doing cool yeah I mean I
don't do it anymore but or I'm not right
now in my life but me I will but
yeah um I keep in touch with the kids
with your films do you seek out the
subject matter or does this sort of come
to you and out of discovery you say you
know what this is what I think I want to
film I know with the great speeches from
a dying world I think you took what a
year to get to know some of the people
there it was that in your mind from the
beginning to film them or do these
things sort of just have a roundabout
way of coming to you and then you go aha
I'm going to film this that one was more
a conceptual in the beginning you know I
I had an idea to work with homeless
people and to hopefully work in somehow
them doing famous beaches from history
um and then I basically just the idea
just kept kind of breaking down and you
know it didn't come to me I mean you
have to spend so much time and patience
just hanging out and and observing and
and you know seeing you can kind of
gently convince someone to talk to you
um I mean some we'll just talk your ear
off it helped and not make any sense but
you just wasted the paper stop shooting
or something and just politely walk away
but so yeah but the other two walking
two burner and bath backwards kind of
kind of more just came to me I guess you
know I mean the walking it took oh but
you know a lot of effort that's not
something that just naturally happens in
your everyday life walking for two
months but um but the idea just kind of
came to me and
you know and then bass ackwards was was
yeah it was like 10 we only road a
little bit and then it was just this
idea that kind of kept building as we
were shooting that I couldn't have done
without the commitment of Shawn Porter
the cinematographer was really a
collaboration between me and him overall
so it was it was sort of an
improvisation on the road I thought
that's what it seems to me is that right
that it you didn't know when you started
filming you didn't have your full script
you wrote it as you drove and went yeah
yeah which is really stressful I can es
it I don't think I could see a movie
like that again not not for a while um
yeah we actually less on the road
because the road the time we're actually
driving across the country we just were
rushing you know because it's tough
money to be on the road and so that was
I mean I described it like pearls you
know just like watching them like fall
through a drainage you know great or
something it's just like you're watching
all these opportunities go behind he had
60 miles per hour and we towed that car
that's in the film a lot of the time ah
and it just would have taken forever to
drive with that car um so so yeah that
was frustrating i think in the future
maybe if i do things that are improvised
i'll kind of know the parameters born
how much time and too a lot for that
time and stuff so we I didn't finish
that movie till a year after we made
that trip we we shot more footage that
was both be on the road but it was just
upstate New York quite a few scenes and
but more in the beginning it's like we
just started shooting and we didn't even
know if it was going to be a movie
necessarily
it was just almost like screen test but
it was it really you know people
describe when you start making a movie
it's like from that initial first day
you're kind of setting the tone and
setting just something and we just kind
of kept setting these little these
little postmarks for ourselves that kind
of told us what it was going to be it
because sean is so short quarter so Oh
get such a great feeling to a and
something such a light cuts against us
so uncle gets a strong passion and ideas
if it worked out
with walking to Verner where were you in
your life before you begin that because
from watching the intro it seemed like
you were at a point where you felt like
you had to sort of create something and
put something out into the world and and
you interviewed this gentleman who says
you know what I spent too much of my
time working and I wish I had followed a
dream so where were you personally when
that film began when that whole journey
walking from my yeah I had I actually
unfortunately got into inhaling OH glue
of different kinds of glues anything I
can get my hands on it and you got
pretty specific we've had people take it
different directions has gotta I've
gotta fix it up here okay Oh turn back
on that regard yeah octo recoger kisses
okay all right no I just uh you know um
what was I doing I was I stop
babysitting and i decided i want to
thank movie you thought I didn't know
how it would go about doing that and i
had made you know shot some footage my
grandmother i was working with the a
dance theater company and we were kind
of still touring a you know that show a
few cities and so it's kind of getting
by a little bit but I was living with my
parents for a while and then I moved in
with my friend Dana Hanson who produced
the film so she just kind of yeah so it
was a really special time for me it was
kind of making completely faith based
decisions and I was lucky enough to have
people kind of holding me up while I was
you know walking you know into the
unknown and into the land of like no
kind of security and no job and stuff
like that you know Linda's went when
you're dealing with the unknown and
you're sort of working with with these
projects where you know you don't
actually know how they're going to end
or in
they're improv or whatever the case may
be what goes off inside of you that says
okay I'm not going to give up i'm not
going to walk away from this story you
know even if it takes me years to finish
this I'm going to finish it ah I don't
know I'm glad I I'm glad I've ever date
I've had that that energy I don't know I
have a good energy once the momentum
starts building you know um and you know
I mean I guess Myrna hertzog is always a
great inspiration for filmmakers anyone
who's accomplished you know great film
like amazing that they got done
especially you know some of the things
he's done so he was a great inspiration
but I'll you know I don't know
self-hatred goodness me you just
whatever works at the end of the day
until like a few years later you realize
well maybe maybe those types of fuel
don't work as well let's see what the
the green the green fuels our
self-hatred is a silicon looking kind of
cause pollution so to speak in you
that's interesting I'd love to hear and
i'm sure the audience would too about
your experiences at nyu at the
experimental Theatre Wing what what did
you take away from that that you still
that still inspires and affects you when
the work you do oh well that was a great
program I guess I mean it is and they I
found that it was inspiring to see that
other kids were doing all kinds of
things like you know they're independent
projects and people are writing and and
singing and you know doing music and
their shows and so I think it's a
program that kind of taps you into a
creative creative spirit and kind of
breaks you down in a certain way
so that you don't have preconceived
ideas of what it means to be creative
like I eat just acting or whatever no
that was really good for me so it didn't
feel as much of a stretch like when I
think I wanted to filmmaking because I
was already doing kind of performances
some work comedic and some were kind of
experimental theatre so that was good
and I had a teacher Rayna von waldenburg
who is really great and uh just really i
don't know i'm really i guess excited by
people who have such a a rigorous and
expansive mind about what things should
be and they're kind of always looking at
things from a different angle and you
know she would give great great advice
we were doing a scene in class and and
the kids would do it one way and they
thought it was like oh that's probably
wrong because they're laughing and it's
like a dark scene or something and then
she's like wait wait wait why would
don't stop maybe why isn't that the
scene you know so that was really
exciting you know because you can imply
that kind of energy in that kind of
twisting of perception to lots of such
situations lynus I want to go back just
quickly to something you said about the
fuel of self-hatred being poisonous to
sort of a creative project what are what
are the healthy biofuels that you used
Wow well corn ethanol what are you using
yeah I'll devo oh well I think it can be
just specific and thinking about the
work and what you want to say with that
type of work you know like the the not
like even a message but just what's
exciting to you about that that work you
know you just have to tap into that and
what's sad about filmmaking is it has so
many some
apparatus that kind of gets in the way
and it makes that the time between
inspiration and execution sometimes very
long you know and so it's hard to so
during that time I think your your
interest which is the green fuel can
dissipate you know and you have to try
to find ways to reignite that interest
and I think also if you haven't just a
just a deep desire to communicate and
should show you know just it's like a
very almost childlike or it's just very
simple and I think at different times in
your life if you have that that can be a
very helpful thing you know because
you're kind of always it's a way that
this your to keep interested if you
weren't acting or making films then how
would you satisfy those creative
impulses that are within you and how
often have you gone through life with a
phase of being sort of inactive
creatively well i have just been in a
very uncreated faith so and it's tough
on me you know you you feel like you can
you can do it and you can with land it
but it's it's not worth it it's another
form of like a pollution or something I
don't know if that metaphor is working
here but anyway so the last like oh no a
year and a half it has not been very
creative so hopefully that will change
it's changing its changing well Ennis
let me talk about that because
creatively I feel like I'm in a space
right now where I'm not sure I can get
another project off the ground you know
I have at least five ideas that I would
love to be the sort of dive in and
develop every day I just feel mounting
pressures coming from all over the place
you know not the end of the day we have
to make films that are viable in order
to keep making them coach me here
Linda's what what you know help me out
here what can I do
I don't know I think I don't know my I
mean I don't I mean I really like to run
a Hertzog quote money has two qualities
um stupid and something I can't remember
stupid and necessary frankly right now
even if I do the boys that money has two
qualities Olympian Cowardly Cowardly
yeah so it can I think that's good to
remember you know I mean uh you know I I
really am interested cuz I'm trying to
you know this is where I'm not gonna
make myself sound very viable but I mean
the things that have carried me through
and given me the most energy and and
therefore that I think usually leads to
successful things are projects where you
have that that really a swirling kind of
passion to it where you're not worrying
about the end result you know you know
someone like John Cassavetes is a real
inspiration I mean rereading his book
Cassavetes on yes that aids is always
good enough on creative periods you know
I mean yeah you just I'm that's
important to me especially for this next
one and for my next film to to make it
so that everything is just right kind of
organically or as right as it can be
feeling wise because at the end of the
day is you know you have this film that
you made and i don't know like so what
it's just like it's got to be about what
it can do for you while you're making it
you know and what I don't know just the
hope the experience of it is really
important and I think I've lost track of
that at points everyone has but how can
you kind of
create a situation where you know it it
feels really good and well you know I
not just that you're just you're rolling
around on the ground oh that felt so
good did you get it I read not just some
like crazy hippie stuff but you know and
it's I don't know that it's just right
you know you're not doing it for kind of
like other reasons like Oh would this
make it better or more successful I mean
I I thought I say that but they also
have a deep respect for audience you
know and I and it's it's always for the
audience you know well it's also for me
you know and the experiences for me but
the film is for them so i might as well
enjoy it while it's happening you know
because in the opening room you make
those tough decisions you know it's not
for me we have producer actress
elizabeth car joining us in studio here
today and we are on the line with
filmmaker LG she stretches out her arms
there we love to see that we're on the
line with filmmaker lynus phillips and
it was two years ago back around this
time that Glynis you found out that bass
ackwards was in sundance how did you
find out the news and what went through
your mind at the time the producer of
the film Thomas Woodrow called me up and
uh yeah good phone call I bet okay um
did that experiment can you talk a
little bit about your experience there
and and how that did it change your life
some people I know people who don't get
into Sundance think if they had gotten
in it would change their life so lynus
did it did it change your life I'm
thinking secondly but go practice your
dance moves for the gregorian video are
you going to your diary entries is that
what you am I going to my diary and yeah
I was really kind of thinking about it
cuz what does that mean I mean
try to imagine my life I guess if I
didn't get in but and if I hadn't had a
cell phone there although it doesn't
really hasn't really changed my life too
much I don't think I mean I kind of feel
like I just kind of was burnt out after
that and dropped out for a while from I
guess making films and stuff so I don't
know so I I think it could probably I
could have probably taken more advantage
of the connections and things but you
know that can come I still had a film
there and that's good it's so it may be
the initial thing was it's just like
nice to tell your your crew because they
they worked on this thing first for you
know most of the time free and so that's
just like the greatest gift you can give
to them you know it's like you want to
make a good film and then that's like
reward in itself you know they you know
to also have it recognized by such a
great festivals it's just you know
really great it makes it feel like all
your all your crazy like rambling ways
where we're kind of worth it you know
not to justify any flaws or whatever but
um and then also just like with your
family it's nice because they they're
they're less on your back about Uncle
like things and pursuing the right
recognition helps with that with getting
getting the family support what would be
your advice Lynn is to those who don't
get into Sundance you know you'd sit
someone down and you can soul them and
what would you tell them i have friends
didn't get in but you know i'm just i
would just talk to them about the the
next project or something you know oh
but not to say that they at project dead
in the plans linea but I mean that's I
don't know um what would I I guess
I mean it's just a it's a bummer when
you get your hopes up for something like
that of course there's other film
festival everything at allow you know
have a trick whatever you know and
lettuce you know you are moving on to
your new projects now you know are you
seeing an impact that you know sort of
having the Sundance pedigree you know
has that had a favorable impact on
getting these new projects off the
ground um I guess I'll oh I could tell
you better in like a couple months or
something yeah because I'm kind of
gearing up i'm still finishing writing
something so i need like another draft
or two to start approaching people yes
sir how you work but yeah no I mean I
think it's a nice thing to just throw
out there you're at a film it's on man
you know what I mean it's great because
it still doesn't like I mean I guess
bass ackwards is available at least two
x which is nice but it's not like i
don't know i don't think like a lot of
people heard about it but it's great
that being at Sundance gives it at least
of the film world and also just you can
just tell people you made a film and
it's just it's like crickets until you
say sunday for certain people so and
that's fine I don't I don't you know I
mean so it's a great thing what they've
done you know because it's not just like
some some name you know there's also
such such good intention behind what
they do and the program so um but yeah
where were you today I'm wondering have
you done anything with Sundance ins like
any of the Institute programs in the
filmmaking workshops or producing or
writing or directing was that something
that intrigued you or
that you would maybe I'll go find out of
us more of that stuff I've never I was
kind of not I just like I said Khan just
bit my own thing the past year and a
half or so no so um maybe in the future
I don't know sometimes those things
scare me though cuz you like wait a long
time and it can slow the process down
and and I probably should have just done
them because I haven't gotten anything
going but I I kind of like the idea just
that you can just pull the trigger and
just start making a film but maybe
that's probably not gonna happen because
I am trying to do things in a in a
different way than I've done them in the
past and color yeah I'm sorry Lin escote
you know coming out of a festival like
that and having the notoriety and the
acclaim come with it you know I mean are
you are you do feel pressure you know
currently in terms of your next project
is that something that goes through your
mind at all yeah I guess it kind of
changes things just um in a good way you
know because I might have just made
another very small film that's partly
improvised and you know and also partly
where you're getting people to do things
for so cheap or free which which weighs
on you you know it's not a fun thing to
do all the time so so it's important you
know so after that it's kind of like
you're like well okay you kind of got
into a big festival like that you should
I feel like a natural you might as well
try to do things different and like a
little a little bigger a little more
professional ha jokes or something like
not have your dad and in it or something
else I mean I don't like that it
although i don't know the truth right
you know I um I loved him in that role
yeah
so yeah I mean the next thing it's going
to be kind of like more mixture of you
know like a still kind of a small movie
but a little bit bigger I feel like and
I'm trying to work with I'm excited
about doing more acting so I'm were
talking to a couple filmmakers and kind
of collaborating on scripts with them
for movies that all acted so I think
that would be good I probably should
have done that earlier like in this past
year when I wasn't ready to make my own
project because it's also very sad for
directors who only make a movie every so
often you know like like what can you
like so you don't learn as much you know
because you you come back to your some
photographer and he's done for movies
since you work together you know because
they're just trying to work and you know
they they're not generating this whole
idea and scripted casting and real
realizing the thing so anyway but they
get to learn so much and experience
things and not wallow in their own
depression in their apartment so well
it's also the difference is over
somebody working on a film and the film
being your film I mean when you're the
writer director that is your baby and
you have to stay with it and and immerse
yourself and for the next 12 so
sometimes I are Patricio che our
cinematographer and radio free album
a--the his just shot a film that's in
Sundance this year and he works all the
time he's so wonderful and I sometimes I
envy that compartmentalized job of being
an actor or a cinematographer but then
on the flip side is you don't get to be
all have all the collaboration and
creativity of creating something amazing
you know like like john l and simon the
writer director of radio free album at
did on our so I hear what you're saying
linis
I admire and I know how hard that is and
it really is sometimes it is just
getting up in the morning and living
with pain and suffering and creating or
not it you know but you're they're doing
it and I have so much respect for
writer-directors I just I don't think
there's any harder job or more
fulfilling so hmm like that living with
the pain yeah and some joy oh yeah no I
like that I thought she wish to the plot
yeah I should have a moment Assad for
you yeah I wanted to talk about how you
have this wonderful raw feeling and
beautiful images in your film and then
it's twinge with this loneliness and I
want to talk about that take us to the
line you know to be miss of life is that
Verner speaking through you yeah yeah
here making some some scrambled eggs
okay and kicking a shoe yeah right Oh
like Charlie Chaplin right yeah yeah the
loneliness is you know I don't know that
something i can do well someone what
once this wants to cast me in something
and I said why do you want to cast me
you know and he said well you know you
have this is real kind of loneliness to
you that I like he could go and it was
like oh ok I mean that's good I I know
what you want to see you know in your
thing but um it also was like hi I guess
I kind of do this is interesting um yeah
I guess I've we wasted a lot of time
being one for having this like kind of
feeling like that I like sometimes you
said something like raw I think that
that's a good quality to have in a film
hmm well I think to the loneliness I
mean eyes the people that are hanging
out and having a great time all the time
they're not really doing a lot so I
think that introspection and that
loneliness and maybe feeling a little
bit like I don't belong in the world and
i'm projecting my own stuff here but you
know just i think that that
helps people you you don't belong though
i don't know i don't hear sorry we
should have told you right but i think
that that contributes because i think
the people that are that feel like
they're part of the crowd they're so
busy with the crowd that they're not
creating so all right and he said that's
hopeful sometimes running from pain or
filling yourself up with other things
it's it's it's temporary and if you sit
with it it can be a wonderful thing I
you know so I'm a big I'm a big believer
in loneliness and and spending time with
herself and all that hey can I I would
love to ask lynn us about his
grandmother oh yes because um I have a
Nana to linda's who was a big influence
on my life and a real regret of mine is
that I never made a film about her and I
know you did sushenka which translated
is enough so tell us about her tell us
about your Lithuanian grandmother uh
salomi doba of a now came over in the
wake of World War two and she's kind of
amazing like she's I mean she's so human
but also into such different way she
cute then what we know you know it's
just so simple I think a lot of people
are like that but I also just uh I know
she's just built she's still alive she
just turned hundreds and uh maybe yeah a
hundred or 101 but anyway she and
Richard said she's in kind of and well
into dementia living and nursing home
and stuff but you know more tough for my
mom such a strange thing it's almost
like some people are just like a family
member said she was meant to to you know
live to 70 in Lithuania you know she was
that's how she was built but then she
came and had an easier life in a lot of
ways and so she
this is built to last you know like she
won't die you know if you would say like
enough already it's a these amazing kind
of almost dark things but not trying to
be dark house is just like like you
would come over and and she you say
house how you doing and she goes that
giveth at giver which is still alive
like now I'm still alive you know just
kind of it slightly annoyed by it but
still like something deep down that is
programmed her to live it's just like
Noah's rewriting the software or
something I don't know I mean but it's
fine i guess she she might get some joy
at living sure he's got excellent but um
she would ice when I was shooting her a
good time because it was kind of before
she was fading so it's nice to have that
I mean she isn't a real sweetness to
earn in something very classic you know
like like potato chips I want to go back
to what we talked about in the beginning
which was for walking to Verner you sort
of opened the film with this gentleman
named Robert and he talks about how he
was always focused on money and working
instead of having a dream and you know
since so many people's money situations
have dwindled over the past few years
and we're all kind of left wondering
okay what's what's the reason we're sort
of still doing all this why are we
getting up in the morning what has ruled
you money having a dream or both and is
it possible to have both no no pressure
we had a deep question yeah um life can
I get a lifeline sure you know you can't
avoid money all together um but it's you
know I guess like a lot of things if it
gives you anxiety you have to try to you
know just
kind of fix that so it's not you know
affecting the way that you're you're
feeling you know I mean you have to
still do things and make money if yet
you know but I don't know I just I I
mean obviously in the since like two
thousand four to two thousand eight you
know like what I was I made two films
two and a half films at that time and I
really just lived like I slept in an
office for a couple months I was living
on people's couches in basements and you
know so really just didn't care about I
went to an extreme of just following
your dreams so to speak and I'm glad I
did I'm kind of still trying to kind of
still find the balance now yeah so that
you can keep doing it and you know like
when you get older it changes a bit
there's priorities change absolutely oh
really oh yeah you just get a little
weaker so you have to just kind of make
sure you can keep you know doing the
creative projects oh yeah the pain is
felt a little more yet mostly in the
back that's where most money troubles
resonate in the battle I want to thank
our guest host today Elizabeth car for
joining us thank you so much and
pleasure for more on Elizabeth please
visit her on IMDb google+ twitter at
elizabeth car and that spelled k a
double r and then her site Elizabeth car
calm on facebook and at Radio Free album
youth com thank you joining us great
seeing you thank you my pleasure and and
I am opening in a plan December 29 that
match a theater in West Hollywood so
people can come and see me be faster
said about behind the scenes and infos
on your site yeah well not yet but it
will be all very cool all right that's
great you know and make sure those you
listening you know connect with with
Elizabeth on Twitter she's fabulous at
Elizabeth
car we've also been speaking here our
guest today filmmaker actor lynus
Phillips for more on linis please visit
bass ackwards film calm you can check
them out on IMDb check out all these
trailers all over on youtube and you
know can I we're excited to see walking
to Verner my personal email is Hello
Kitty at AOL done there you go nice
that's pretty pathetic in such okay
that's great there's other work includes
great speeches from a dying world
Linda's thank you so much for joining us
here today iPhone Kurds yeah we really
want to see more stuff from you we just
love your work great to meet you Anna
skirt yeah yeah thank you thank you are
are you know we had our last film
courage interactive of the year on this
past Monday we screened missing pieces
by filmmaker Ken Bartlett and the short
film fidelis by Jonathan Chi fur we had
an awesome night and two great films and
then to top off the night we had an
amazing QA with both filmmakers and
their main actors we had Kenton Bartlett
and the main actor of missing pieces
mark boone junior and also Jonathan
Schieffer and the main character of
fidelis I hope is saying his name right
as Xander generat and their photos and
video are up on film courage calm yeah
and that's our last one we're going to
resume the film career actives in
January you know we take the same yeah
we take December off and then we'll be
back january thirtieth 2012 with the
feature santiago by writer-director
felix Marty's and the short film the
terrain we're going to get the screen
this time around by writer-director
winder and as always thank you Ronan for
all that you do Ronan is helping us
build film courage calm to be a
wonderful site and he also runs the
board here at la talk radio we look
forward to being here with you next
sunday at noon la talk radio com we're
going to be joined by the team behind
becoming Santa a documentary of one man
entering the culture and character of
Santa Claus for a single season becoming
Santa follows jaq as he bleaches his
hair goes to Santa school and tries to
do everything
that Santa is asked to do he works a
sidewalk or as a sidewalk Santa he does
home visits a Polar Express train and a
parade along the way Jack collects
children's wishes and learns about the
benefits of belief the history and
origin of Santa and the ordinary people
that keep the Santa spirit alive and we
just got the screener in the mail so we
can check that out you know get into the
holiday season the film won the South by
Southwest audience award and we're going
to be speaking with the director Jeff
mayors and writer of the subject doc
Jack Sanderson for more information on
becoming Santa please visit becoming
Santa the movie calm and becoming Santa
on Facebook and until next Sunday as
always have a great week
you